hi I'm Michele from lab muffin Beauty
science today we're going to be talking
about collagen supplements if your
interview tea and skin care you may have
seen collagen supplement surround and
you'll have seen claims like how taking
collagen will smooth wrinkles boost
firmness and make your skin more elastic
but do they really work since I have a
PhD in medicinal chemistry I needed to
check out the evidence for myself here's
what I found
[Music]
collagen is a protein which means it's
long chain of amino acids chemically
joined together
collagen is an incredibly important
protein that's part of what's called the
extracellular matrix this holds the
cells in your body together it's also
found in bones tendons and tissue in
your skin collagen lives in the lower
layer called the dermis it's important
for giving your skin structure and
elasticity which translates to bouncy
skin as you get older your body produces
less collagen it's estimated that skin
collagen drops by about 1% per year
there's also a change in the types of
collagen in your skin so you end up with
thin wrinkly skin that's more prone to
damage damage from the environment can
also destroy collagen sun exposure and
smoking are especially harmful
that's why sun damage skin looks older
and sunscreen is so important
[Music]
so logically eating collegeand could
give your body the building blocks to
make more collagen unfortunately you
have very little control over what your
body does with the things you eat eating
plants doesn't mean we end up green and
able to photosynthesize and make food
from sunshine eating a miracle won't
make you glittery no matter how much you
want to shine look at those time look at
those charm like I mentioned collagen is
a protein made up of lots of amino acids
joined together in your stomach and
small intestine you have enzymes that
will break up proteins like collagen
into smaller fragments so you can absorb
them into your body so most of the time
when you eat a protein it will get
broken off and your body won't be able
to tell which protein you've eaten but
collagen has a special amino acid in it
hydroxyproline in humans hydroxyproline
is only found in collagen so when you
eat collagen you'll end up with
hydroxyproline in your blood so your
body can tell you've eaten collagen but
does this do anything
[Music]
they have been a bunch of studies where
collagen supplements improve skin and
mice and rats and even pigs it's also
been found that after eating a collagen
supplement human volunteers have
fragments of broken-down collagen called
prolyl hydroxypropyl in the
in-vitro prolyl hydroxylase fragments
were found to make human skin cells grow
faster and produce more hyaluronic acid
another component of the dermis
hyaluronic acid keeps the water content
in your skin high which is also
important for bouncy unwrinkled skin but
the study doesn't tell us anything about
whether the fragments get from the blood
to the skin in high enough
concentrations to actually do anything
which is sort of absolutely crucial to
whether or not collagen supplements work
so it doesn't work in actual people
here's what the clinical trials have
found so far in one study by a
supplement company volunteers took 5
grams of hydrolyzed collagen made from
fish cartilage every day along with
other vitamins and minerals after 60
days dryness wrinkles and the depth of
the nasolabial fold
that's the groove between your nose and
cheek improved and after 12 weeks
collagen density and skin firmness also
improved but most parts of the trial
didn't use a placebo control so it isn't
as reliable and of course there's the
bias issue in another study volunteers
took either a daily supplement
containing two and a half grams of
collagen peptide or a placebo for eight
weeks there were improvements in eye
wrinkles as well as pro collagen and
elastin content of the dermis the trial
was run independently by a university
the same supplement also improves skin
elasticity four weeks after the
volunteers stopped taking the supplement
ten grams of a daily collagen peptide
supplement was found to improve skin
hydration after eight weeks and
increased density and decreased
fragmentation of collagen in the dermis
after four weeks according to placebo
controlled trials run by the menu
chara survive now you're probably
thinking that we should all immediately
run out and eat all of the collagen
supplements but before you spend all
your money I have to burst your bubble a
little bit with some inconvenient facts
one of the big issues with supplement
studies is that they offer new
supplements that contain ingredients
other than collagen as well so you can't
say for sure that it's collagen having
the effect and not the other ingredients
for the non placebo controlled trials it
could also be something else entirely
causing the change for collagen it's
particularly tricky because there are at
least 28 types of collagen collagen is
also made up of thousands of amino acids
most studies use collagen that's been
hydrolyzed or broken up but as you can
imagine with a chain that's thousands of
amino acids long you can break it up
into different lengths so a supplement
with collagen that's a thousand amino
acids long might not have the same
effect as one that uses fragments that
are a hundred amino acids long or fifty
amino acids long or ten amino acids long
so even if a study finds a beneficial
effect with one collagen supplement it
doesn't mean that a different collagen
supplement will also work if that's not
enough another issue is that a lot of
these studies are done by companies who
sell the supplements so there's an
obvious conflict of interest it's
unlikely that they'll publish data that
show that there isn't any effect and
it's likely that they have massaged the
results to look as good as possible
here's the verdict collagen supplements
are pretty promising and could
potentially work but the evidence is far
from solid only a few collagen
supplements have gotten good results in
studies and collagen supplements can be
very different and most of these studies
were run by the companies that sell the
collagen supplements so they're likely
to be biased the results also don't
really find that collagen supplements
actually increase collagen and not just
improve your skin through other methods
like increasing hyaluronic acid or just
indirectly changing your diet
for example if you drink more collagen
face supplements maybe it makes you eat
less sugar because you'll fall from the
water and it's actually the lower sugar
that improves your skin if you have the
budget
there isn't much harm in trying collagen
supplements as long as you don't have an
allergy but if you want the best bang
for your buck
I'd recommend trying more proven ways of
protecting and increase in your collagen
first preventing collagen from being
destroyed in the first place is much
easier and more effective than trying to
repair your skin later so make sure you
wear a high UVA protection sunscreen
daily one study found that collagen gets
damaged with about one-tenth of the UV
that causes a sunburn
so not burning doesn't mean your skin
isn't being damaged vitamin C is also
great as an antioxidant for soaking out
free radicals that cause sun damage and
it can also increase collagen as well
vitamin A derivatives known as retinoids
are the gold standard for increasing
collagen in your skin particularly
threatenin glycolic acid has been found
to increase collagen in some studies as
well if you want to get more hardcore
chemical peels can increase collagen so
can laser and IPL light treatments if
you want to go super basic you should
make sure that your skin is adequately
hydrated dehydrated skin is a really
common cause of tired looking skin and
it's very easy to fix
look for serums and moisturizers with
humectant ingredients that help your
skin hold on to water like glycerin and
hyaluronic acid to plump up skin and
hide wrinkles that's all from me about
collagen supplements I'm sure there'll
be more research through non collagen
that tells us more about whether or not
it actually works if you like my video
I'd love it if you could subscribe to my
channel you can also follow me on
Instagram and Facebook for more Beauty
Bayside's tips you can also check out my
blog for tons and tons of Beauty signs
see you next time
[Music]